et pas assez là les enfants vous laisser
tourner la pièce passe pour pas sauvera
pas d'alcool pattaya présentait pas le
même âge pour un temps guide
voilà prêt à laisser tomber
je pense qu'il faut pas couper tout le
temps parce qu'après on est les jeux
picards est super bon ce carré avec les
a eus pic devait liquider mignard est
bien serré c'est magnifique samassa
d'écran c'est très beau ça va ce qu'est
la route à côté
bush car trop vite au goût des supers
dans des super l'ordre n'ont pas trop
dramatiser après que malgré le froid les
super lentement la tenture rigole ou
parme a joué dans la m eur c'est pas
rapide quand même à 80 qui reste en
attendant les patates région vainqueur
il aura peu large un peu large un peu
large pour monter vos sorties on se
chambre devait sortir comment ce truc a
continué
après comme entachées l'horizon en fait
assez bien ça pour de trop vite ça pour
moi les retraites en hiver l'horizon
jorge aspar s adresse adresse adresse
ok ok bon coup et le live de phase iii
dans la glace ghost par un juge et de
suite lui échappe ou juste de survivre
et moi je pense conclut reza shah prend
part klan kkk klu toujours dessus qu'on
le voit bien
frank barrera part de rien que vous
pensez bien et le centre offre
voilà c'est pas bien c'est bien à tout
doucement tout doucement au rsa c'est
joli
voilà et on repart vers la 3e série
contre laquelle elle aurait préféré
qu'on l'a su par l'arrière alors là pas
partir trop tard michel tu pars trop
tard et là je ferais quoi on ne tutoie
pas passer au dessus on va passer au
dessus et ils veulent pas on va pas si
mal reçue par l'arrière comme option
je peux pas l'enlever un bain en passant
par derrière en soule helicopter ben si
partei comme tu partais avec je parle
pas la roue les pages parle pas dans
rouler là alors parle de droite par
devant et de passer derrière comme si on
regardait avec ça passe je parle voilà
comme ça voilà ça je voulais faire bien
il a faim ou pas ça je suis obligé pour
passer au dessus sont obligés de
l'enrouler si je veux la voir derrière
vu qu'on le prend devant au départ tu
passes devant tu vois pas le talent et
sa voix non cinémascope s'est pas privé
c'est bien voilà tout acerbe sur bar
dessus alors que c'est là tu vas
commencer à l'heure où le chocolat se
ferait qu il doit se retrouver à verser
un ace le faire de doute entendu tout
doucement badakou côtoient doucement
voilà on passe au dessus à trop taloche
le budget du coup là le pouvant être aux
trois pics pas si on crache au dessus
sur le géant qu'est ce qui est facile
s'échapper alors dans la vie pour passer
laisser s'échapper
plus qu'un césar autant on va voir ses
peurs doucement en rdp d'horizon tanguy
plus tôt mais le temps a passé mais
partait trop tard barkat en compte un
petit peu compris tout ce pan plusieurs
outils quoi voilà très bien et
dès lors derrière il va ainsi lui est
souvent il yal'art derrière kg lieu ok
ok ok contre 8 p lâche laisse le
laissent leur est que ça sent un peu
partout ce mandat là ok sortir les
environnements voilà qui repique pas
pour faire feu plan tarp